From the moment of birth
Convergence information is committed to technology
To shape an efficient, connected, and trusted business world
Hello everyone, I am Lei Xiaopei.
Scanning the head of the Almighty King Development Team
Convergence information is a unicorn company in the field of artificial intelligence + big data
Focus on text recognition and understanding in robot vision
Scanning Almighty is one of the company's core products
With nearly 400 million global users
Is the world's most downloaded text image management application
Scan Almighty King will phone, tablet
Become a scanner, fax machine, file library that you can carry with you
Relying on the tools and platforms provided by Google
Scanning Almighty King has achieved great success
I am Wu Zhongze.
Is scanning the all-round king development engineer
Very early on, we set out to adapt to Android 9.
Removed some of Apache's network libraries referenced by third-party SDKs in advance
Tested and adapted to the latest power management features and non-SDK interface limitations
It also adapts to the limitations of the background services commonly used by applications.
Application for permission with front desk service
Notification enhancements that can give users a better experience, Liu Haiping, etc.
We have also made a comprehensive adaptation
Android Jetpack provides rich development components for our developers
Improve everyone's development efficiency
Jetpack's permissions component
Well adapted to the permissions of various mobile phone manufacturers
Avoid specific adaptations to the model
I am Bu Lingzhuang.
Is scanning the all-round king development engineer
We are committed to creating a universal, easy to use, easy to use efficiency software
So universal ability has always been our focus.
Google in the MR1 version of Android O
Support soft decoding of HEIF static graph
And in the latest Android Pie
Upgrade to support HEIF format decoding and encoding
HEIF format as a new image format
In many ways better than the older generation
For example, smaller space usage, support for dynamic images, support transparency, etc.
We have updated import support for HEIF image formats.
The current experience is good
And we plan to post the app update later
Join the export support for 9.0 system devices
Give full play to the new features brought by the new system
Create a better system + software experience environment
We look forward to being the most intelligent and trusted business platform in the world
I hope to be promoted by Google’s new technology.
We can provide a more efficient and intelligent user experience
In order not to change the initial promise
Customer value